aux radios spoutnik
à l'excès venediktov
messieurs vindictus vous avez une belle
musique là derrière
avec c'est possible et je n'ai pas à
faire c'est de ne pas broncher cette
musique pour le respect qui
nous avons du journaliste en direct avec
nos premières vraiment je donne la
parole magarita simonian
merci beaucoup collègues nous avons déjà
commencé que le compris que le direct a
commencé
je suis un confinement comment vous
voyez malheureusement je voudrais vous
serrer la main mais je voulais le faire
de manière virtuelle vous m'entendez je
vous entends je vais moi même
je suis un confinement parce que les
conséquences sont exceptionnels les
conditions sont exceptionnelles
chére monde entier également non
seulement concernant la pandémie logique
en ce qui concerne la géopolitique je
vais commencer par la question que tout
le monde se pose maintenant est que nous
mêmes nous nous posons dans notre pays
et dans tous les autres pays il y
aura-t-il une guerre cela profite nous
avons envoyé nos propositions nous avons
attendu la réponse nous avons eu la
réponse la réponse ne nous a pas
satisfaits on aurait pu s'y attendre
avant le disiez différentes personnes
disaient que si la personne la réponse
ne nous satisfaisait pas on se réservait
le droit de répondre par des mesures les
plus sévères et de défendre nos intérêts
par les moyens les plus sévères
pouviez-vous expliqué monsieur leur
offre qu'est ce que cela veut dire que
ce que nous allons faire on va pas
interdire mcdonald's si je cite mes
abonnés c'est la question
ce qui se posent quand est ce qu'on va
frapper washington demande se demande
s'il y aura t'il une guerre et combien
de temps va continuer à discuter
si ça dépend de la fédération de russie
il n'y aura pas de guerre nous ne
voulons pas de guerre
mais on
permettra pas porter aux français nos
intérêts et les ignorer
je peux pas dire que les pourparlers
sont terminées parce qu maintenant que
vous le savez les américains et les
mamans de l'otan ont mis en moi à
étudier nos propositions qui sont tout à
fait simple concernant en projet de la
core 2 quad tonné avec l'alliance d'un
ta fatigue nord nous n'avons reçu la
réponse pierre et les réponses sont dans
le style ordinaire de
l'occident ont peu flou mais là on
trouve de grands rationnelle mais pour
des questions malheureusement secondaire
pour nous c'était assez important à
certains étape il s'agit des missiles de
petite et moyenne portée lorsque les
américains ont
se sont retirés de l'accord nous avons
lancé des appels à
pour le raisonnement du président
américain nous avons foi en foyer le
l'appel à tous les membres de la cee en
leur proposant de s'associer à un autre
accord unilatéral à l'époque c'était
ignorer mais maintenant ça fait partie
des réponses
de même que l'initiative composé par
notre temps major général consistant à
faire éloigner les manoeuvres militaires
us de nos frontières à concerter les
distances limite de rapprochement des
aéronefs militaires et des bâtiments de
guerre en mer bon bref curie des mesures
de des conflits d'âge ce qui a été
négligée et refusé pendant les deux
trois années précédentes maintenant on
propose de les discuter alors les grands
constructif qui était a inclus dans ses
réponses on les a pris on les a hérité
des initiatives russes mais alors on a
réussi quelque chose quand même mais
l'essentiel pour nous c'est de
trancher sur des bases fondamentales
concept de la sécurité européenne en
2010 astana et avant en
1999 à istanbul tous les présidents et
les premiers ministres des pays faisant
partie de l'essai eux se sont signés
ont déposé leur signature à un paquet ce
document ou aurait affirmé
l'ensemble des principes de à
l'indivisibilité de sécurité l'occident
il prend seulement un seul slogan chaque
pays a le droit
de liberté pour le choix des alliances
militaires mais là dans les documents ce
droit est conditionnée par une condition
par un engagement de charles bishop pays
qui encore une fois a été a approuvé par
les présidents ne n'est pas renforcer sa
propre sécurité au détriment de la
sécurité d'autrui
l'occident en prenant
la politique des portes ouvertes de le
temps et que personne ne peut interdire
à l'ukraine de l'entrée le temps c'est à
le temps et a le crâne de trancher le
dessus mais l'occident y vite d'une
façon soigneuse même des références aux
conditions qui ont été prévues par les
documents 30 bar bar el houb linkin
d'autres collègues parlent d de la
nécessité de suivre les principes
concertée dans le contexte de
l'architecturé de la sécurité dans la
zone de l'atlantique et de l'europe
personne en effet référence à la
déclaration d'istanbul ni à celle de
astana on parle d'acte final d'helsinki
et de la charte de paris ii en
1990 pour la nouvelle europe où on ne
trouve pas
les engagements en ne pas renforcer sa
propre sécurité au détriment de la
sécurité d'autres pays mais dans les
documents qui ont suivi la russie a
insisté pour inclure
engagement est aujourd'hui pour me j'ai
déjà prévu aujourd'hui nous allons
envoyer des demandes officielles à tous
nos collègues avec une demande directe
de nous donner une réponse officielle
commenter ce qu'il se prête à respecter
dans le contexte actuel les engagements
qui auront été prises par leur pays au
plus haut niveau
c'est une question fondamentale avant de
passer à aller pour parler pour des
questions aux ponctuelle de sécurité
européenne nous voulons voir comment
l'occident je vais vous le dire on va se
débrouiller cette fois ci mais moi
j'espère que là ils vont répondre
sincèrement honnêtement ce qu'elle
sous-entend en
tempérant ses engagements d'une façon
signé latéral d'une façon
particulière
en supprimant en négligeant complètement
la condition que le droit aux alliances
militaires est conditionnée par le refus
de renforcer sa sécurité au détriment de
la sécurité d'autres états
si jamais
la réponse qui ne satisfait pas du tout
alors que durant les relations parce que
tous s'entendent au ce dernier des
américains ils sont prêts à introduire
des sanctions contre tous les dirigeants
qu'on trouve personnellement contre le
président ça veut dire que même moi je
suis pas digne d'être sanctionné quoi
jamais vu ça dans l'histoire a parlé des
sanctions à l'égard du ministre des
affaires étrangères du président ça
dépasse déjà des limites en plus sur ce
fonds
regardez ce qui se passe avec nos
diplomates la déclaration hier de
l'ambassadeur de russie aux etats-unis
qui a dit que tout ça pourrait mais en
fin de compte
à une rupture des relations parce que
nos diplomates sont expulsés même si ça
s'est présenté d'une manière un peu
différente soeur
la question plusieurs facettes
je vais commencer par les principales ce
que nous allons faire si l'occident
n'écoutera pas la voix de la raison le
président a déjà donné les réponses nos
tentatives nos efforts à convenir aux
principes
[Musique]
de sécurité en europe
nous allons prendre des mesures des
réponses en répondant à la question
directe quelles pourraient être ces
mesures et l'a dit les mesures peuvent
être tout à fait différente et moi je
vais prendre les décisions selon les
propositions a donné par nos militaires
évidemment d'autres ministères ont aussi
participé à la préparation de ces
propositions
honnêtement on
réalise la concertation entre
ministérielle des réponses reçues de la
part des états unis et de le temps le
contenu est déjà connu mais or je peux
dire entre parenthèses que
[Musique]
les réponses reçues par le temps
si on compare le réponses données par
les américains sait on peut dire que
c'est un exemple
des traditions diplomatiques parce que
la réponse de le temps et 30p
d'idéologie de ce sentiment de leur
exclusivité de leur mission particulière
mais bref les propositions concernant
les réponses à donner sont en train
d'être rédigée au niveau
interministériel ont emmené en train de
travailler là-dessus et on prévoit aussi
des spas dont je viens de parler en ce
qui concerne les menaces des sanctions
on a dit aux américains y compris
pendant les contacts entre les
présidents que ce ensemble des sanctions
donc que romain vous venez de mentionner
où on prévoit le blocage des systèmes
financiers et économiques est contrôlé
par l'occident ce serait équivalent à la
rupture des relations s'étaient dit
directement jeu
juste je pense qu'il le comprenne je
pense pas que ce soit aux intérêts de
quelques ans ensuite concernant leur
comportement par rapport à nos diplômes
diplomate il y a quelques années je ne
me trompe pas au mois de décembre 2016
c'était ma dernière visite à washington
c'était le dernier mois d'administration
de temple et là entre autres en se
disant au revoir le vice secrétaire
d'état les recettes non c'était pâti de
penser aux il a dit à mon adjoint et à
l'heure à propos nous pensons comment
pourrait-on optimiser le fonctionnement
de nos missions diplomatiques à titre
réciproque et alors nous vous annonçons
pour nous les américains les diplomates
font 3 le les mandats de trois années
dans le pays ensuite sont
révoqués aux halles à paris centrale et
nous avons décidé que
pour vous ça pourrait être aussi
intéressant et nous proposons de suivre
le même un le même système trois ans
deux mandats pas plus et lorsqu'elle a
demandé pourquoi est-ce qu'on le déclare
a entre autres en se disant au revoir et
des mêmes propositions à d'autres pays
la réponse était non au camp d'autres
pays n'est pas envisagé comme un sujet
d'une dentelle expérimenté destiné
uniquement à la fédération de russie
c'est à l'heure où on a commencé encore
une étape de notre je dirais aux
positions diplomatiques alors si c'est
votre pratique que les mandats doivent
durer deux trois ans notre pratique
c'est de ne pas engager le personnel
local pour l'entretien de l'ambassade et
eux ils en ont l'habitude d'embauché
quelques centaines
de personnes
en tant que personnel local j'ai alors
nous avons suivi cette discussion
des exclamations des soupirs alors que
faites vous vous nous coupez les airs
alors écoutez si vous avez voulu suivre
ces principes que
vous avez le droit pour tous et vous
pouvez nous imposer ce qui vous voulez
alors nous allons faire la même chose
c'était une spirale de crise qui a été
commencé par obama qui a fait preuve de
son vrai caractère à trois semaines
avant son départ de la maison blanche et
l'a voulu a frappé de la porte
il nous a enlevé cinq sites diplomatique
et l'a expulsé des dizaines de
diplomates qui ont dû ensemble avec les
membres de leur famille faire leurs
valises en quelques jours seulement
c'est là où tout a commencé
maintenant nous avons des discussions
vous en avons parlé avec linkin à genève
en
cdi.notre pour par nos pourparlers pour
la sécurité nous proposons de remettre à
zéro
tout ce qui a été fait dans ce contexte
à partir de ce1
de lauréats nobel obama
annulé tout ce qui a suivi ça
on va voir dans deux semaines on doit
avoir une rencontre
mais pour le moment c'est du marchandage
de la part des américains alors nous
pour l'ambassadeur
faut douze personnes à ses services et
il faut les faire sortir du quota qui a
été
débattu de façon réciproque nous leur
expliquons que le quota de 400 à 55
personnes pour nous et pour eux que ce
quota de notre côté ça hein reflète en
geste de bonne volonté très forte parce
que dans ces quatre cent cinquante cinq
personnes ont fait en plus non seulement
les employés des missions diplomatiques
de l'ambassade et de deux consoles à la
dent ce nombre on voit 150 employés de
notre représentation auprès de l'onu qui
n'ont aucun lien avec des relations
bilatérales
en tout état de chose ça c'était dans la
démonstration de notre bon volonté mais
nous leur avons prévenu que si
vous n'acceptez pas
nos propositions
en disant que si vous acceptez pas de
exclure ces douze personnes du nombre
total on demandera votre ambassadeur
antonov de quitter le pays alors on nous
avons donné notre réaction
c'est avocat bonjour monsieur ministre
charles collègue monsieur la fois vous
savez très bien que normalement je me
base dans mes questions sur les
questions de nos auditeurs je rappelle
que nous avons avec nos messieurs lavrov
le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères donc ma question
on va suivre aussi cette ce domaine des
relations russo-américaines main que
maaf l'on nous a envoyé cette question
c'est un professeur de stanford pourquoi
la russie n'a pas cherché à avoir
l'approbation du conseil de la sécurité
de l'onu pour l'application de force
s'il y a le besoin d'appliquer la force
dans la question ukrainienne est ce que
la russie ne croient plus à
un conseil de sécurité de l'onu et
pourquoi la russie n'a toujours pas
reconnu la république les républiques
autoproclamées de nets reculs sont sous
la même menace que le city et la quasi
en 2008 mais
alors la question sont pas corrects du
tout
tout d'abord la question qui concerne
le conseil de sécurité
si j'ai bien compris cette question
pourquoi la russie n'a t'elle pas saisie
c'est du passé n'a t'elle pas saisi le
conseil de sécurité de l'onu pour
recevoir l'autorisation aux deux
utiliser la force si ce serait
nécessaire moi je vais pas même expliqué
lance tous les enfants c'est de cette
phrase le moci n'existe pas dans les
pratiques diplomatiques de tout le pays
en ce qui concerne la reconnaissance si
je me trompe pas c'était la deuxième
partie de votre question oui
je pense que mike mcfaul
ensemble avec mon apport à la
destruction de tout ce qui était dé
constructif dans les relations russo
américaines n'a pas eu le temps au de
lire les accords de minsk qui ont été
signés en mode février 2015 où il s'agit
de conserver lui l'intégrité
territoriale de le cren ce qui a été
fait en situation où
pendant ou plusieurs mois avant
c'est se rencontrent cette rencontre de
minsk dans les républiques
de le gars que de proclamer leur
indépendance et l'allemagne et à la
france qu'ils ensemble avec nous et les
israéliens en signer le texte des
accords de minsk ont demandé
et prochaine qu il a aussi
au cul nous sommes
nous ont demandé de convaincre les
leaders des deux républiques de a posé
le silure signature à ces accords de
minsk
en changeant les résultats de référendum
qui a eu lieu en 30 ans
michael mcfaul il doit prendre
connaissance de l'histoire moderne de la
région
parce qu alors cette question ont posé
sur la reconnaissance doit être
envisagée dans le contexte de notre
ligne directe qui vise à faire de
manière que kiev respectent les accords
de minsk alors c'est là où tout sera en
norme comme c'était prévu par ce
document qui a été approuvé je dois vous
dire par le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
bonjour mais cela mof
je pense que beaucoup de ceux qui ont lu
le document que vous avez proposé
aux américains ont été surpris beaucoup
ont le sentiment et moi aussi j'ai ce
sentiment que la russie a déjà gagné une
bière et l'amérique a déjà perdu une
guerre je parle du radicalisme des
propositions à revenir aux frontières
des années
précédentes ma question justement c'est
qu'est-ce que c'était c'est évident que
les américains ne reviendront pas ça aux
conditions de
1981 17 et ne vont pas se retirer des
pays où sont si bien positionné d'une
manière aussi confortable et donc nous
avons tenu vous avez pris un contre
quelque chose mais comment
et quoi
on vous attend dans les réactions à
cette lettre
là il vous avait demandé de répondre au
rap humain
quelles étaient vos considérations et
c'est le quatrième équipe américaine
avec laquelle vous travaillez à
commencer par george bush y at il une
différence de principe entre ses équipes
y à t'il ce rôle du personnage
historique où ça n'a aucun sens avec qui
avait vu un travail confortable avec qui
c'était pire commence à travailler avec
ces cette équipe là non propositions qui
ont été envoyés le 15 décembre aux
américains et aux mamans dans le temps
c'est propositions peuvent pas être
limité
seulement si l'expert qui les
étudient ces bases je pars des bases que
les américains ont déjà tout prix alors
ça sert plus à rien de faire quoi que ce
soit il faut
prendre ce qu'on nous donne et se
satisfaire du minimum non nous voulons
qu'on perd avec nous de façon honnête
moi je viens de citer aujourd'hui les
engagements qui ont été prises au plus
haut niveau et ont été signés et compris
par le président américain que qu'il ait
eu personne ne va pas à renforcer sa
sécurité au détriment d'autrui les
américains nous disent le droit la
liberté des alliances est sacrée et nous
rejetons sous condition que ça ne porte
pas le tort à la sécurité des autres et
vous vous lavez signé les américains est
maintenant l'heure ce qu on fait
l'effort de présenter notre proposition
comme un ultimatum
c'est ce que nous voulons faire pour ne
pas les laisser
éluder les conditions des engagements
prise
si on se base
du fait que la russie ne sera jamais
recevoir la réponse positive à ces
questions alors là on peut le prouver on
pourra le jouer mais ça c'est seulement
après ce que nous avons
parlé des ses engagements de ne pas
élargir le temps ce qui a été dit dans
les années 90 et on nous répond alors
c'était oralement fait et c'était pas
très bien compris c'était dix ans at on
n'a pas voulu alors maintenant lorsque
nous sommes sur notre propre territoire
et les américains dans le conseil de
sécurité de l'onu dont mike mcfaul vian
de parler et les américains se prête à
étudier ce qu'une faisons l'égard de
l'ukraine est pourquoi nous ne prenons
pas
des escalades est ce assez prononcés par
les représentants du pays qui a fait
implanter ses bases militaires tout
autour de la russie tout autour des pays
de l'est si tu fais on sait pas quoi en
irak ou de personnes dans les autres
matches ne l'a pas invité alors si les
américains veulent envisager le sujet
concernant le déploiement et le
positionnement des troupes à l'étranger
alors là on a de quoi parler nous ne
sommes jamais
quelque part sans l'invitation du
gouvernement local en conformité totale
avec le droit international
alors maintenant on nous dit en
attisant le sujet du façon hystérique et
de cette escalade
ukrainienne et borel blinken
ils disent alors nous espérons beaucoup
que les russies choisissent le voit dire
de les promotions vous pend sur parole
parce que mon âme et plusieurs décennies
à cette choisir cette voie diplomatique
et le résultat notable de cette
diplomatie
sont les accords que je viens de
mentionner d'istanbul et d'astana et
notamment que personne ne renforcera pas
sa sécurité au détriment de ceux de la
sécurité d'autrui c'est ce sont des
accords c'est le résultat ultime de la
diplomation conso su sans compromis
si vous êtes pour la diplomatie alors
tout d'abord respecter ce qui a été
signée
en ce concerne bond nouvelle équipe je
vais pas passer à des appréciations
personnelles
son sujet assez
[Musique]
large mais moi j'aime pas parler
de nos partenaires en donnant ma vision
personnelle ce sont les partenaires
travaillent avec et en général je dois
dire qu'avec que tous mes collègues j'ai
eu des relations stables on se parlait
toujours
sincèrement même pour des questions qui
se faisait même des questions qui
étaient assez épais neige au niveau
international
donner la parole à sonic sur la bof vous
êtes diplomate on n'allait jamais
formulé ça comme je vais le faire mais
moi je suis journée je peux me le
permettre
j'ai déjà informé les quelque chose je
pense oui c'est vrai mais vous le faites
pas devant le micro et dans le cadre de
l'interview si on essaie de co2 de faire
des trucs comme ça et de vendre des
t-shirts avec vos expressions après vous
avez sauvé kazakhstan maintenant on va
peut-être sauvé la situation entre le
tadjikistan et le kirghizistan nous
avons récemment à sauver
la paix dans le haut karabagh et dans
l'arménie on continue de sauver nos ex
si on peut dire qu'est ce qu'on a
en échange les collègues de monsieur son
gorkin qui est dans le studio de
komsomolskaïa pravda maintenant on fait
une enquête exceptionnelle et ont publié
de très beaux matériaux
sur ce qu'on écrit sur la russie l'union
soviétique le pire des deux tiers dans
les manuels dans les écoles de dans des
pays de l'ex union soviétique que nous
avons sauvé c'est très passionnant à les
lire vous allez être surpris mais sur la
route si vous le lisez il nous rapporte
que la langue russe fleuri dans les
écoles kazakhstan selon nos informations
c'est le contraire pour les russes dans
ce pays il y a vraiment beaucoup de
plantes le complète sur des cas ou
d'intimidation jeu par un principe
beaucoup de voix avons nous entendu
parler que le ministère des affaires
étrangères était se poser à ce que ces
citoyens obtiennent la citoyenneté je
sais que ce n'est pas du tout le cas
nous avons discuté de ça je sais que
vous avez apporté votre contribution
pour simplifier la législation pour
donner cette saignée site était
jusque-là va-t-on tolérer cette aptitude
inverse non nogent quand va-t-on faire
tourner nos gens selon le principe
éthique comme l'ont fait les grès que
les allemands les juifs est comment
va-t-on défendre les droits de nos
gentils suite la défaite du pays qui
n'ont pas voulu ou sont restés là m'a
fait vraiment il ya beaucoup de
questions dans cette question tout
d'abord à ce qui concerne les relations
avec nos voisins nos alliés dans le
cadre de le dk bo décès est ici dit elle
c'est ce vraiment le problème existe
personnes le cacher surtout ce problème
est lié avec le fait qu'il ya des
nouveaux états indépendants
qui ont apparu
suite à la disparition de leur et c'est
ce qu'ils font fait partie et de l'ain
pyrrhus par le passé pendant langue
période et story ce qu'ils ont eu la
chance la possibilité de créer leur
propre état le propre états nationaux ce
que j'aimerais souligner
là dessus évidemment l'aspiration à
démontrer affirmé sa propre identité
historique parfois et parfois lié avec
des mesures ou des pages excessif et
passons values liées et tout ça arrive
chaque fois qu'il ya des grands empires
et se démontaient les comme par exemple
l'empiré russe et le successeur de
l'empiré russe c'était pareil à ça a été
fait de même avec une des questions plus
souple le plus historique par rapport à
l'héritage de lempiras
français aux britanniques mais vraiment
et dans ces périodes historiques
actuelles et ce sont des choses
excessives qui sont inévitables que nous
voudrions surtout éviter
prévenir et surtout le faire par toutes
les mesures par tous les moyens en
utilisant ce qu'on appelle la sorte
power
évidemment ce pour lequel on va investir
plus de ressources par rapport à lui
nous faisons actuellement actuellement
notre ministère fait de son meilleur
pour que les gouvernements russes
prennent des décisions nécessaires pour
que la politique dans sur cet axe soit
active is est ce que les pays les deux
occidentaux font actuellement parce que
nous sommes le mans par rapport au
niveau qu'ils ont acquis actuellement
dans cet axe du travail est est
actuellement à part le pouvoir doux à
part la diplomatie est vraiment la pose
de cette question lors des contacts avec
nos partenaires nos alliés qui a encore
la réciprocité
et qui s'explique par le bus devant de
prendre en considération les relations
envers les questions qui nous intéresse
lors de l'étude qui intéresse nos
partenaires en russie je parle des
travailleurs migrants oui si je parle de
la favorisation économique ainsi que nos
systèmes économiques sont liés entre eux
en plus l'union heureuse ya tic
économique et créer des connaissances
dont la majorité
seront réalisées et mises en oeuvre par
la russie bien sûr et là dessus je vois
qu'une contradiction quand on parle du
développement des relations amicales
personnel très proche avec nous allier
avec nos voisins
j'aimerais répéter
que la situation géopolitique est lié
avec une catastrophe géopolitique avec
la disparition de l'union soviétique
comme monsieur poutine à notre président
déjà dit de ce coût 25 millions se sont
retrouvés à l'étranger à l'époque et
personne à l'époque on né sait comment
il fallait agir pour remettre un bon
niveau nécessaire les relations la
communication le fait qu'aujourd'hui la
situation s'est normalisée plus ou moins
est aujourd'hui plus ou moins chacun
comprend de quoi il est responsable
c'est déjà un grand acquis mais les
questions que vous avez mentionné
surtout les estampes de nos compatriotes
à l'étranger évidemment ils doivent être
résolus sur une base réciproque et dans
ce contexte j'aimerais marquer le fait
que par exemple le premier point
nous devons
agir dans le cadre de l'essai 8 d'une
façon plus active plus ouverte des
problèmes des droits des êtres humains
surtout des gens
qui font partie et surtout et sur le
principe et nicky a par exemple je parle
des russes qui se trouve au kazakhstan
ou des casaques et qui se trouve en
russie des herbes à djénine qui se
trouve en arménie hall inverse même s'il
y en a pas beaucoup
finalement nous avons réussi à avoir
l'accord de nos partenaires dans le
cadre de l'essai 8 pour les médias parce
qu'à l'époque de lâcher les suit quand
il a été créé dans sa chair nous avons
une crise que nous allons établir une
commission chargée des droits des êtres
humains mais chaque fois on n'avait pas
lui tourner acer ont manqué du temps
surtout à l'étape initiale l'occident
voyait qu'eux il ya va pas mais pas
assez d'activités concernant les droits
des êtres humains mais ces dernières
années la russie a posé la question
pas ce qui s'est déjà écrit dans la
charte de la série il faut qu'ils se
soient mises en oeuvre il ya déjà un
accord commence que cette commission
chargée des droits des êtres humains
commencent à fonctionner parce qu'on va
traiter cette question dans le cas de la
communauté des états indépendants sont
surtout le fait pas ce que chaque fois
qu'il s'agit du jugement des trois des
êtres humains il faut que ça se soit ion
nous les états membres de la ceni est
pas les structures occidental et qui
puisse en juger surtout par exemple la
cour européenne a chargé des droits des
êtres humains qui a perdu il ya
longtemps si je me trompe pas de se
baser sur le principe
et chaque fois ils essaient de politiser
à la question et qui traite en plus un
truc au point que vous mentionnez
margarita les compatriotes qui veulent
revenir
dans leurs batteries là
je pense que c'est vraiment à nos
intérêts il faut qu'il revienne et
surtout
surtout les parents les amis les
familles surtout pour
vraiment développer les femmes il les
affaires mais vraiment c'est vraiment à
nos intérêts de tous les états membres
de la communauté des états indépendants
tous les états indépendants de l'acca de
l'assaut il faut que les gens restent là
où ils sont nés et là où ils vivent dans
leur pays évidemment ça nécessite la
disparition de toute forme de
discrimination dans l'idéal moi je
préférais que les russes vivent a
calmement au kazakhstan avec prospérité
dans les autres républiques
ex-soviétiques m mais ceux qui veulent
évidemment changé
2 leur lieu d'habitation domicile
évidemment il faut créer des conditions
pour l'assurer aujourd'hui nos voyages
beaucoup de gens uci qui aimerait
améliorer un petit peu les conditions de
leur vie
évidemment là dessus
du pont de vue de la préparation des
décisions nécessaires à préparer en
russie à des dépositions de différentes
ministère les agences associées sentent
qu'ils se croisent un particulier et le
ministère des affaires étrangères russe
agit pour la libéralisation maximum de
ce processus surtout ces dernières
années déjà avec la participation de
notre ministère de l'intérieur et
d'autres ministères nous avons prises en
compte et nous avons adopté plusieurs
amendes de monde plusieurs modifications
des lois et surtout par rapport la loi
basiques de 2002 et ces amendements
visent à le faire disparaître
pour ceux qui veulent obtenir le
passeport russe lice la citoyenneté
russe c'est surtout la disparition du de
l'exigence au moment de la demande du
passeport
prouver la source des moyens pour
l'existence parce que cette exigeante
n'existe plus surtout pour les
ressortissants de la république est
socialiste et russes et soviétiques
surtout pour les parents pour
les enfants on a
refusé et on a fait disparaître
l'exigence pour avoir l'autorisation
pour l'existence temporaire au le séjour
temporaire en fédération de russie est
juste il ya quinze jours à peu pris à
moi le 29 décembre notre président
se mit à l'étude de l'assemblée fédérale
la nouvelle version de la loi fédérale
portant sur la citoyenneté parce que
nous avons travaillé sur ce document
avec tous les autres ministères et les
agences concernées
ce projet élargit considérablement
les motifs mais bénéfique pour obtenir
la citoyenneté
et ça concerne aussi les déclarants est
vraiment leurs parents et leurs membres
de leurs familles qui ont vécu sur les
territoires de la république socialiste
et russes et ça concerne la
simplification du processus ultérieur
pour obtenir la suite tenté quand on
parle des étrangers surtout quand on
parle à des personnes sans citoyenneté
ça concerne aussi la culture usa langue
russe
surtout qu'on parle des gens qui sont
capables de s'intégrer avec une bonne
réussite dans l'onglet société russe et
je pense le fait d'inclure cette fois
c'est extrêmement important surtout
quand on parle des membres de famille
mais quand on parle des ressortissants
de nos écoles supérieures et quand on
parle des citoyens et des personnes sans
citoyenneté jeu par des participants au
programme d'état qui prévoit le
déménagement de north et sorties sont un
peu pris à 60000 personnes
qui ont rejoint ce programme est déjà au
niveau des programmes régionaux si on
les prend en compte le nombre total
dépasse 80 mille personnes y compris la
région de transe baïkal l'extrême orient
parce qu'il y en a beaucoup qui
aimeraient déménager en fédération de
russie j'ai restée tout à l'heure les
vraiment les avantages des principaux
que nous avons prévu mais nous voudrions
un pouvoir encore plus et fournir plus
moi personnellement je pense que
l'existence des racines de ta propre
famille de tes parents un républicain
socialiste russe et dans d'autres
républiques soviétiques et ex soviétique
doit pouvoir importance pour que vous
puissiez bénéficier des avantages si on
parle de votre citoyenneté russe
éventuel possible futur et surtout quand
on parle des questions
que nos trios résoudre le plus vite
possible évidemment le travail n'a pas
fini et actuellement nous sommes en
train de capitaliser ce que nous avons
déjà discuté par le passé surtout notre
président déjà validé le consensus à qui
et nous allons continuer ce travail sur
cet axe dans le but de faciliter les
conditions pour avoir la citoyenneté
russe surtout grâce à l'initiative du
président russe nous avons mis en place
et la commission
par notre pouvoir politique russe le
parti russie unie dans qui est chargé de
la développons et de l'assistance et du
soutien de nos compatriotes à l'étranger
parce que ç'a pris voici lé l'assistance
à nos compatriotes à l'étranger aussi à
les six stations compatriotes dans le
sens que nous avons disputé votre
première question pour qu'elle puisse se
sentir dans les conditionner le plus
confortable possible
je demande pardon aux romans en plus on
a mentionné l'article eu dans
komsomolskaïa pravda si je me trompe pas
c'était écrit dans un bouquin de
l'histoire est qu'ils étaient publiés
dans le but expédié tic je veux pas dire
commenté ce qui est écrit par les
douaniers à un crayon l'étudiant et et
d'autre mais en ce qui concerne les
états de la communauté des états
indépendants nous avons déjà attire
l'attention pendant les dernières années
sur le fait qu'il faut pas donner aux
nationalistes des motifs des prétextes
pour roba les y aider si j ai vraiment
difficile de notre histoire comme un sûr
il faut que ça ait des tous les peuples
qui ont vécu qui vivent toujours sur cet
espace énorme géopolitique vraiment
surtout dans certains cas il faut qu'ils
créent d'une part vraiment leur étoile
et
leur identité nationale et surtout parce
que les nouveaux étages qu'ils étaient
de s'affirmer dans ce contexte mais il
faut surtout éviter des estimations
excessive
qui a dit au façon intentionnelle
parfois sont joués par des
ultranationalistes ultras radicaux
surtout c'est sur toile grâce à notre
initiative dans le cadre de le tc
l'année dernière nous avons réussi à
faire saigner la décision qui eux voient
la mise en place d'une commission avec
la participation des scientifiques est
l'un des axes principaux de ce
fonctionnement de ces commissions c'est
discussion commune des points des
questions historiques
je pense pas que nous allons
publier des
manuels les historiques communs mais
quand même il faut d'une part
démontré la variété à et des différentes
estimations historiques mais évidemment
c'est déjà prévu surtout il ya une
commission des scientifiques historiques
avec l'allemagne avec la pologne avec la
lituanie entre autres et dans l'ensemble
dans certains cas il publie des
documents communs et je suis sûr de dans
le cadre de la coi
mécanisme similaire va fonctionner qui
va prendre en compte et y rapprocher nos
positions sur plusieurs questions et
dans le cadre de plusieurs associations
de onia lisation de coopération de
shanghai ocs tu essaies et les autres
qu'on bossait merci monsieur lavaud je
voudrais revenir dans nos relations avec
les américains je
veux dire que le travail va se
poursuivre et jora cette réunion avec
catherine quesne
d'ici quelques semaines mais aujourd'hui
après avoir créé sur leur réponse tous
les experts presque tous les experts
disent culture que les maraudes de la
temps le temps ne vont pas changer leurs
positions sur les questions principales
c'est ce qu'ils disent c'est que ils ont
jeté la balle du côté de la russie sont
prêts à tout variantes possibles vous
dites et le président a déjà dit que
nous allions prendre des mesures de
réponse ces mesures de réponse
ces mesures seront travaillait aussi
avec le ministère des affaires
étrangères on voudrait comprendre dans
quelle direction le ministère va
travailler pour qu'on puisse leur
redonner cette balle l'a rejeté
l'amérique latine venezuela cuba
peut-être c'est ça ou peut-être c'est
l'orientation européenne
on peut peut-être faire quelque chose
dans la direction de l'érable pourriez
vous nous donner une idée de la réponse
qu'on devrait donner pour que ces gens
là et commence à réfléchir et à nous
donner des réponses à la question
principale
s'ils insistent et qui vont pas changer
de leur position évidemment nous
n'allons pas changer de nos positions
parce que leur position se baser sur des
motifs fo
c'est vraiment sur
les mensonges du canton pandy fait
historique parce que par contre notre
position c'est l'inversé c'est pour ça
que je vois pas de possibilité pour le
compromis parce que deux quais l'entente
de quels accords et nous pourrions
discuter parce qu'il sabote les
décisions du passé et c'est pour ça que
pour nous ce sera vraiment un test
l'examen clé à ce qui concernait les
épées
et en ce qui concerne les balles
là dessus
il faut pas
se débarrasser de la responsabilité ce
que nos partenaires américains essaient
de faire mais je dis encore une fois ce
sera pas possible d'éluder la réponse à
la question pourquoi est ce qu'ils ne
respectent pas à ce qui a été signé par
leur président quand on parle du
renforcement de la sécurité au détriment
de l'être humain ce qui concerne votre
question
concernant une relation avec elle les
états de l'amérique latine la serbie
l'iran la chine il y à beaucoup d'autres
aux états
qui ont un comportement correct sur
l'arène internationale et qu'ils
essaient de rien imposer aux autres
en respectant les accords bilatéraux
ces relations ne subit aucune
conjoncture passée qui sommes vraiment
riche et se développe assez qu ils
couvrent des questions humanitaires
économiques et sportives est aussi
militaire militaro technique comme la
coopération militaro technique
en stricte conformité avec les règles
internationales et je veux vous rassurer
que 1 dépenses de mon du développement
des événements concernant la sécurité
européenne nous allons développer et
nous allons intensifier ses relations du
façon consécutive mais la réponse que
nous avons obtenus nous sommes en train
de l'étudier nous avons déjà fait part
de nos premières estimations
évidemment ce qui concerne le problème
essentiel le problème principal pourquoi
est ce que l'occident ne respectent pas
leurs engagements concernant la sécurité
indivisible en ignorant nos un terrain
parce que notre position vraiment
extrêmement ouverte est clair
mais ça les a
fait fonctionner un petit peu parce que
le fait que nous avons rendu publics ces
documents en essayant de changer de leur
attitude surtout négatives parce que
quand on parle de en ce qui concerne les
accords sur les missiles de moyenne et
courte portée
ça signifie déjà le fait que l'occident
ne comprend que ce type de conversation
que nous pouvons construire seulement
dans le sens dans la logique nous avons
présentées en présentant nos initiatives
nous allons concentrer je répète encore
une fois nous allons nous concentrer en
essayant d'obtenir les explications
à nos questions en ce qui concerne
l'indivisibilité des frontières et de la
sécurité parce qu'actuellement
l'accident manque les engagements parce
que à l'époque il n'a pas respecté ses
engagements oral de ne pas extrader ne
pas élargir le temps à l'époque c'est
pour ça que actuellement nous attendons
la réponse écrite à notre exigence
écrite expliquez nous comment vous
respectez vos engagements écrits à
assumer par vaux président à l'époque
inconnue
merci je vous rappelle que nous avons
avec nous le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov concernant les
collègues
quand il faut défendre le journaliste
russe qui sont face à des limitations
aux etats-unis en allemagne dans le
cadre de rtc lui on peut le site et on
voit qu'au niveau de mariage à carvin au
niveau de diplomates niveau des vice
ministres et il ya toujours une défense
active de journalistes quand il s'agit
des pays avec lesquels nous avons une
coopération plus étroite votre agence se
comportent d'une manière
différente
peut se rappeler l'histoire des
journaliste de komsomolskaïa pravda
peut-être monsieur senghor qui n'est mal
à l'aise d'en parler moi je peux en
parler le chef du bureau est en prison
et je vous rappelle que l'assassinât des
journalistes 6
en ukraine journalistes quand les
journalistes ont péri en ukraine le
ministère avait une position très ferme
quant aux journalistes ont été tués dans
la république centrafricaine
le ministère s'est tu une question de
dimitri à notre auditeur de moscow il
parle du prix nobel et on y parle
de ça donc sans une enquête
supplémentaire le nouveau un ambassadeur
de la russie à la république
centrafricaine a parlé du groupe 3r le
ministère va être au courant les
familles des victimes non ne sont ne
savent rien parce que les affaires ont
été brûlés
comme preuve il n'y a pas d'action
d'inquièter il n'y a pas de déclaration
du ministère
monsieur larose est ce que le ministère
ne devrait-il peut-être à s'intensifier
ces actions concernant aussi les
dirigeants biélorusses et ceux de la
république centrafricaine vous avez
raison lorsque vous dites que nous
devons toujours protéger les droits de
nos concitoyens non seulement des
journalistes pour les droits de tous
citoyens
et parfois même beaucoup relais pour les
quarts des américains ils sont ils ont
été kidnappés même c'était plusieurs
dizaines et mais pour les journalistes
évidemment il faut les protéger à chaque
fois que nous avons des raisons de le
faire nous avons fait part de nos
préoccupations de ce qui s'était passé
avec le
la rédaction de komsomolskaïa pravda on
en a parlé avec moi des mairies combat
beach et autant que je sache
là il s'agit des citoyens ou d'un
citoyen bien le russe
là c'est une situation un peu
particulière
et là tout tout état
qui
accepte
en double c'est un été ce pays se faire
aider par ses propres lois vous n'êtes
pas sans se voir et je vais pas entrer
dans le détail le dessus là il ya deux
questions qui exigent du silence nous
avons beaucoup fait pour que les
autorités
bio le russe fasse preuve de la
compréhension de la situation actuelle
et maintenant ils ont à une situation
telle qu ils sont d'accord devriez en
poste de correspondant mais sous
condition que les employés seront des
citoyens de la fédération de russie
alors là on peut voir que quel est le
comportement envers les journalistes
russes et qu'elles conduisent quelles
conditions sont créées pour leur travail
à l'occident pour faire la comparaison
et je pense que cette exigence de n'est
pas s'empêcher léa citoyen biélorusse a
pour des rédactions russe sur le
territoire national c'est pas quelque
chose d'extraordinaire mais évidemment
sont pour le respect des droits des
journalistes par tous et sans exception
et dans le cas où ces droits sont violés
ainsi avons nous allons au poursuivre
notre travail à protéger ses droits en
ce concerne
la république centrafricaine la tuerie
du trois journalistes
au nous serons prêts à communiquer toute
information à notre disposition le
communiqué aux proches d un journaliste
qui ont péri en ce qui concerne les
coupables ce n'est pas sans se voir que
ce sont les autorités de la république
centrafricaine qui a
tellement de l'enquète je vais pas
aucunement
justifier les tueurs mais je dois quand
même mentionné qu'il faut prendre des
précautions
si on est journaliste pas lorsque vous
partez là où il ya une menace terroriste
alors il faut
donner l'information aux autorités
à l'ambassade et ça pourrait augmenter
les chances de
survie ils ont visité le pays en tant
que touriste sans déclarer les buts de
leur visite encore une fois je dois dire
que je justifie aucunement cette
tragédie mais je souligne que ce
comportement créer des risques
supplémentaires et excessif à la
sécurité des journalistes
moi je soutiens tous les journalistes
qui travaillent partout et surtout dans
les points chauds et je m'incline devant
les journalistes et qui en leur casque
et de presser et en gilets pare balles
font leur boulot dans les zones docilité
et encore une fois je perds les pneus je
parlais de ce sort des journalistes anne
cren et je m'adresse à vous et à vos
collègues de l'occident pourquoi de
l'autre côté de la ligne de contact à
dubaï cette beauté qui est contrôlé par
kiev les journalistes on lui voit une
fois chaque six mois au mieux et ils
font des reportages à ponctuelles ce
serait plutôt intéressant de regarder
si c'était le même la même situation que
témoignons à l'autre côté à la côte et
des républiques autoproclamées où nous
voyons des reportages qui a noté moigne
des bombardements qui tuent des civils
qui tue les gens et même les tuer des
enfants ce serait intéressant de voir
qu'est ce qui se passe à l'autre côté de
la ligne de contact qu'est ce qui se
passe avec
les habitats
ça pourrait nous donner l'image mais si
on revient à la situation dans la
république centrafricaine
nous avons déjà envoyé le demandent au
gouvernement du pays alors ce que nous
avons eu cette information sur ce groupe
3r nous allons en mener cette enquête à
bout
[Musique]
avec tous nos efforts lorsque c'est le
gouvernement qui en est responsable et
nous aspirons avoir à connaître la
vérité et j'adresse une profonde et
demande à vos collègues aux journalistes
lors de vos visites des points chauds si
vous si vous ne faites pas confiance
qu'on ministère des affaires étrangères
je peux pas vous compte en dhr mais je
vous demande de ne mettre au courant de
vos visites et ça aidera
je donne la parole merci beaucoup
monsieur lavrov pour votre soutien à
notre histoire compliquée de guy nazim
j'ai comme messieurs merci messieurs
avec victor d'en avoir parlé il ne
s'agit pas seulement des journalistes et
mauges et qu elle est en prison depuis
quatre mois
il ya eu lui même aux
entretiens avec lui je saisis monsieur
l'occassion comme n ya pas eu de
réaction mais en fait vous avez bien
précises et ne s'agit pas seulement des
journalistes est aujourd'hui selon les
données de l'ambassade russe en
biélorussie
457 citoyens russes sont en prison
bill russe ça selon les données de la
base ad je pense que ce chiffre n'est
pas complet n'est pas précis
hier encore une personne
a été ajouté à cette liste il s'agit de
victor ianoukovitch et citoyenne russe
elle a été détenu hier pour une seule
chose au moment des manifestations elle
a pris une photo d'elle je peux vous
montrer elle a pris cette photo
elle a fait une en selle fille
vêtue d'une belle robe rouge sur le fond
de cette patrouille elle est en prison
maintenant elle va y passer deux années
deux années et je crois au moins
autant faire quelque chose avec ça
on devrait avoir une relation différente
avec la biélorussie parce qu'on est un
pays allié on est deux pays alliés
mais on voit que nos journalistes ont
beaucoup de mal à travailler beaucoup
plus de mal à travailler en biélorussie
qu'en géorgie un américain en israël ou
dans d'autres pays par exemple
on parle toujours de cet état d'union
que nous avons avec l'habile russie est
d'une nécessité de synchroniser notre
législation mais y at il des chances des
chances de devenir vraiment en est à
annoncer concernant net
alliés comme vous le savez
le tome précédent on a confirmé les 28
programmes
7 a pas publié les ce sont les documents
cadres moi je savais pas que c'était pas
publiés
les ce sont les documents cadres qui
suppose le travail qui a été déjà
lancées concernant données du
substantielle à tous et 28 vecteur avec
des décisions concrètes législatif
d'action directe avant tout dans
l'économie les finances les trans les
transports les télécommunications
s'étant pas
considérable pour consolider la base
matérielle de l'état allié et jeu d'ici
deux trois années comme les présidents
l'on est décédé ces programmes doivent
être
réalisés et cet avancement pour on est à
comment ayant plus de pouvoir
cet avancement en cours encore un
lecteur hier nous avons
envoyé en biélorussie en nouveaux
ambassadeurs monsieur gryzlov moi je lui
ai donné ses lettres de créance
l'ambassadeur à biot le russe monsieur
cmh son excellence monsieur semachko à
participer à cette cérémonie
et moi j'ai
parlé dans notre vecteur à d'autres
travail commun à savoir l'alignement des
droits de nos citoyens de nos deux pays
on a beaucoup fait dans le domaine mais
il en reste encore à faire surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit les conditions d'octroi
des services médicaux des services
hospitaliers pour les gens qui voyagent
à titre personnel là
évidemment c'est très important pour la
vie quotidienne
mais à la question par lequel vous avez
commencé c'est pas lié avec
le futur de notre état comment
parce que même si la législation pénale
est complètement unifiée
probablement où il lui aura des cas
où on aura des russes
arrêtés en biélorussie et vice versa
notre ambassade suit de près les
dossiers des citoyens russes
met en garde en
biélorussie nous avons des contacts au
niveau des parquets généraux en ce qui
concerne hector et de ctv que je n'ai
pas entendu parler de ce cas c'est le
journal d'aujourd'hui
vous avez dire que c'était seulement
guerre qu'elle a été arrêtée une nuit
hier
elle est une employée comme ça moi je
capable non c'est juste une citoyenne de
la russie
j'ai dit qu est presque cinq cents 500
personnes
457 à l cherhal
458e évidemment nous allons porter
enterré à son sort comme le font partout
dans tout le pays oui là encore on a des
questions qui nécessitent une
coopération très étroite des onguents
des mendiants de l'ordre josé part je
veux pas en parler en public pour le
moment ces questions persistent il est
très important que ces questions soient
résolues entre alliés à la fraternelle
nous allons
poursuivre cette ligne de comportement
l'interview du ministre russe des
affaires s'est rangé du rpt déjà une
heure et on va passer à la troisième
partie je vais poursuivre ce sujet
cette question je crois qu'elle doit
être la dernière passe carreau par beau
temps même si c'est pas le cas alors
monsieur lavoie objet une demande pour
vous pas une question je pense que vous
savez de quoi je veux parler je parle de
notre chaîne allemande aux etats-unis au
royaume-uni
nous n'avons jamais eu
des situations où
sans compromis sans précédent
dans l'espoir de 21e siècle
je dirais même pas dans l'esprit du
deffand deux siècles précédents il ya
cette interdiction de travail en
allemagne à laquelle nous faisons face
sous les prétextes hypocrite dirigeants
allemands ils disent que ce n'est pas
nous le fait que si la chaîne du tout
point vous a
interdit en allemagne ce n'est pas nous
mêmes en anglais quand nous avons eu le
plus grande audience aux anglophones sur
youtube youtube ne nous a pas fermé ne
nous est pas interdit mais les allemands
ont su le faire ils ont fait pression
sur le symbole pour ne pas nous donner
de l'essence c'était presque prêt déjà
vous savez que nous avons eu la licence
herbe ils ont fait une pression sur les
régulateurs européens donc nous ne
pouvons pas faire la diffusion à partir
de là des efforts énormes des personnes
qui ont travaillé là dessus qu'ils ont
eu sept pour avoir cette audience tout
ça en vain
le 10 ans
voit que ces intérêts ne sont pas
respectées parce que ce que nous sommes
nous pouvons leur montrer ce que les
autres ne peuvent pas nous montrer
je sais que des mesures réciproques qui
pourrait influencer vous connaissez ça
mieux que moi et que nous tous d'autres
shevell elle n'est même pas reconnue en
tant qu agent de l'étranger même si le
statut de légende ou l'étranger ne
prévoit pas ce qui est prévu en amérique
pour ce genre de choses là s'il s'agit
et de prison de cinq ans chez nous ça ça
ne veut rien dire en effet le fait
d'être reconnu comme agent de l'étranger
ça vous permet de vous prendre des
interviews et s'est révélé n'est même
pas dans agents de l'étranger est fermé
cette chaîne ici on n'en parle même pas
alors que là ils ont fermé notre chaîne
aidez nous s'il vous plaît messieurs les
rohff vous ne vais pas me convaincre
c'est juste que rien ne se passe ça dure
depuis quelques mois déjà meyer
seulement
encore une fois notre ambassade a exigé
des explications
des procédures sont lancées c'est pas l'
agence fédérale qui en est chargée c'est
berlin brandenbourg c'est un régulateur
régionales si je me trompe pas
nos juristes
qui travaillent dans l'ambassade ont
étudié les précédents
et la même situation était pour le
groupe axel springer mais dans leur cas
ils ont reçu l'autorisation assez
rapidement
et elle a le plus important c'est que
les allemands
et c'est de mettre leurs réglementations
internes qui autorise pas à
l'enregistrement des chaînes
d'information les temps supérieur aux
conventions internationales visons la
télé mission transfrontalière et d'après
nos données il s'efforce leurs
régulateurs ses forces à prouver leur
priorité de leur droit interne nationale
s'avérera pas comme ça ce sera la même
chose qu'avec l'élargissement de l'otan
alors là ça me plaît je le prône est ce
que j'ai promis d'autre part je vais pas
le respecte et qu'on venait de dire les
mesures réciproques les réponses on peut
dire tout simplement les allemands le
savent ce sera le cas
lors de la visite de deux monologues
verbot moi j'ai parlé ce sujet et je
pense que mon collègue et sa délégation
on entendu mes propres
et je pense que tout récemment moi je
vais avoir une conversation téléphonique
avec elle et moi je vais ce sujet aussi
merci on attend avec impatience
les paroles
on voit qu'il ya un scandale aux etats
unis ces naines a fait un reportage où
les journalistes ils se réfèrent leurs
sources
et papa parle d'une conversation
téléphonique entre baden et zelensky
dans le cadre duquel m joe biden s'est
indigné contre zelensky en lui disant
que s'il ne changeait pas sa position
sur le don basse qui elle serait capture
g
qui y est c'est râpé ce reportage a été
nous on a disparu après mais dans ce
cadre de cette question de cette
conversation baden exiger la solution de
la question du statut particulier du
donbass
si jamais
il
décide finalement
d'apporter des modifications dans la
constitution de donner un statut
particulier au donbass cela va-t-il
influencer notre politique à l'égard de
l'ukraine pourquoi je pose cette
question parce que nous savons
on ne peut pas faire confiance à ces
gens là alors qu'il ya sept cent vingt
mille citoyens russes dans cette région
il y en aura mais plus probablement on
sait ce que le passeport aarhus ce que
ça peut dire pour ces gens est-ce qu'on
se prépare à ce genre de situation
comment construit dont notre politique à
l'égard des républiques
nous n'avons jamais eu d'autres
positions que celles cependant la
nécessité du respect complet et total
de respecter les accords de minsk à la
succession des étapes prévues par ces
accords moi j'ai déjà mentionné en
public
mes collègues ont fait pareil qu au mois
de juin leurs 2 en contre de petits
n'est pas donne à genève président biden
a lui-même d'après son initiative a dit
il s'est dit prête à
aider à la réalisation des accords de
minsk il comprend la nécessité d'un
statut autonome il a dit même sa
autonome de ces zones en ukraine
ce qui reflète le contenu des accords de
mise que ce serait tuer a stipulé
d'une façon nette alors si washington et
moi je veux y croire parce que anthony
blinken
réaffirmé cette volonté d'aider la
réalisation des accords de minsk que ses
adjoints ont fait de même
ils feront pas partie du format
normandie mais qu'ils veulent aider
s'ils arrivent à
force elle qui hier le respecter et 100
e personne peut pas le faire nous serons
satisfaits de ce résultat évidemment
mais pour le moment
on peut pas y croire facilement
maintenant vous voyez quel est le jeu
ont fourni des armes et je pense que
certains veulent s'y voyait non ce non
pas des
livraisons d'armements mais une marche
encore pour faire dégrader le conflit
pour armer une côte et il faut le
prendre en considération
on voit que sont pas nombreux à le
vouloir mais il y a un groupe qui
pourrait tirer de bénéfices
d'une dégradation de la situation
pourquoi je dis que ce sont les
américains sûrs qu'ils sont en mesure de
forcer le créneau respecter les accords
vous voyez on a eu en leur encontre la
rencontre enfin la normandie des
conseillers politiques
notre délégation était précédé par
monsieur kozak ils sont discutées la
progression des accords de minsk mais la
france l'allemagne et l'union européenne
disent qu'il est aussi est une article
conflit de quad et on parlait encore ils
doivent alors on doit respecter les
accords de minsk monsieur kozak a dit
plusieurs fois et monsieur poutine le
président a dit plusieurs fois alors
donnez vos données de le point des
accords de minsk que la russie doit
respecter mais on reçoit pas le réponse
alors on sous-entend que tout dépend de
nous et nous n'avons qu'à claquer des
doigts et tous ravion mais le kiev il a
compris que berlin et paris ne vont pas
le forcer à respecter les accords de
minsk et comme aux jeunes ce qui a agi
nous n'aimons pas les accords de minsk
mais ils sont importants parce que ça
nous permet de garder les sanctions
occidentales contre la russie c'est du
cynisme pur et rien d'autre et ils
comprennent que là ils peuvent faire
tout ce qu'ils veulent et
on l'utilisé on l'utilisé les skis et
son régime avant tout ce sont des
américains qu'ils utilisent pour attiser
les tensions à
avec
les années en europe qui
font de même et la ligue âge c'est pas
le sort de l'ukraine l'important c'est 2
à attiser la tension autour de la
fédération de russie pour en venir à
bout de ce sujet et s'en prendre à la
chine comme les politologues américains
le disent comment peuvent-ils on venir à
bout de ce sujet je moi je paie pas
comprendre comment elle veut le faire
s'il en reste des politologues
expérimentés je sais pas comment on peut
le voir mais maintenant ils utilisent le
crâne contre la russie d'une façon aussi
a tellement cynique et que même le
régime de qui vivent à 1 a peur ça sert
à quoi d'aggraver les rhétoriques ça
sert à quoi de faire évacuer les
diplomates alors à propos en ce concerne
les évacuations des diplomates qu'ils
font les américains et d'autres angles
sexe les canadiens et les britanniques
peut-être ils savent quelque chose que
les autres ignorent nous allons
réfléchir peut-être en attente
deux
des provocations de quelque sorte il
faudrait prendre des précautions à
l'encontre de nos propres diplomates
dans le pays
mais
les accords de minsk moi je suis sincère
quand je dis moi j'ai déjà répondu à la
question quel est notre opinion à propos
des idées de reconnaissance de
république de donetsk de lougansk ma
réponse est simple il faut respecter les
accords de minsk
sont nombreux ceux qui attendent
tout prétexte pour enlever
de kiev
cette faute de saboter le temps document
approuvé par le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu
si je vous rappelle que nous avons avec
nous le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov
vous avez dit que le secrétaire général
de l'otan stoltenberg a perdu le lien
avec la réalité peut être que vous vivez
dans deux réalités différentes
je suis top ten legs pas être en direct
de moscou à 18 heures aujourd'hui
le
limbo trier peut-être lui poser une
question ou le dire bonjour les
téléspectateurs de moss un
téléspectateur de moscou l'auditeur ce
regain de moscou c'est ça
oui
donc j'ai regardé la liste des sanctions
de l'année dernière comme roman vient de
parler des sanctions les sanctions
prises par le congrès américain la
majorité des sanctions était lié avec le
nom d'alexis navale n'est il pas avec
l'ukraine
là où l'organisme international de
l'interdiction des armes chimiques a
fait une expertise
et indéfinie par trois laboratoires
indépendante
donc il ya les résultats ont montré
qu'il a été empoisonné
qu'il y a eu des agents
qui ont été retrouvés dans ses analyses
le ministre la russie n'a pas débuté
d'inquiets tu pédales donc il n'y a pas
eu but est de la france le ministère
continue t-il
dans le cadre des relations avec
l'occasion d'interdiction des armes
chimiques
de coopérer
dans le cadre de cette question
chaque organisation internationale
européenne
voit qu on nous assomme en minorité
quand on parle de la bce ont dit qu'ils
sont des russophobe aux essais on dit
que ce sont des russophobe et
l'organisons des armes chimiques ont dit
la même chose dit toujours ça elle
assure votre patrie c'est quoi encore
c'est pas l'organisation de tradition
d'armes nucléaires
ça ressemble un peu alors hier encore
j'ai regardé euronews
j'ai regardé est revenu ce et là j'ai vu
un reportage au village de vanille en
géorgie à tout proche de la frontière
avec coeur le style du sud
et là c'est le village qui est située
sur le territoire que la georgie
affronte pour son propre territoire et
le reporter le dit alors moi je suis
hélas dans le village de douane hydra la
ligne de séparation derrière mon dos
c'est la frontière ministre et yves qui
est renforcée par la russie est la
maison qui appartenait en géorgien cette
maison a été brûlé pendant le conflit la
nouvelle maison que ce géorgien vient de
construire à mettant dans la zone
d'observation des militaires russes et
les locaux en compte à l'heure la seule
kidnapping peur des moyens en plus
féroce toujours féroce et là on a un
journaliste local gauguin on montre
comment il travaille pendant plusieurs
années dans les villages proches de la
zone de conflit et qu'est ce qu'ils
disent moi j'ai même pris des notes et
l'animateur 10 14 ans après la guerre
qui a forcé les gens vivre dans des
conditions supportables presque chaque
jour ils perdent leur terrain leurs
parcelles les gens sont kidnappés le
soldat russe les arrête et ensuite suite
et ensuite on continue et après cet ego
à qui claude journalistique qu'il a dit
et ensuite c'est l'animateur après un
muret cesse la géorgie et première parmi
les républiques de l'ex union soviétique
a ressenti l'escala de séparatisme et
des hostilités et des milliers de
réfugiés n'arrivent pour le moment même
pas de rentrer dans leur pays
là on n'a pas parlé de quelle sorte de
séparatisme on a eu en géorgie même
avant l'effondrement de l'urss lorsque
comme ça court 10e a exigé que les apps
soit de se faire assimiler et les
ce type de sud ont ils des traités même
pas comme des humains ils exigeaient
qu'il sonnait
et là on dit que pendant 14 ans les
soldats russes kidnappe les gens locaux
elle a encore une fois zh en 2008 lors
de la phase chaude du conflit la russie
a pris à la pause sur le site seed sud
ça c est revenu ce qui est assez réclama
d'être la chaîne la plus juste à
l'exemple de la multitude des opinions
en parlant d'un conflit fratricide
cette chaîne ne raconte n'aime pas les
racines à les sources de ce conflit
alors vous avez posé cette question sur
la l'organisation d'un terrifiant
d'armes nucléaires sen a présenté les
points de repères qu'ils doivent être
élucidées si on formule la question
qu'on vous l'avez fait alors mike mcfaul
et d'autre
auditeur expérimentés peuvent quoi que
c'est vraiment la vérité et lorsque vous
dites que nous avons demandé aux
allemands de données de cette
explication ils nous ont répondu alors
lancé en dossier un pénal alors nous
présentons la formation c'est quoi ça
les engagements de l'allemagne y compris
concernant l'aide légale dans le domaine
des services d'enquêté ces engagements
ne sont pas liés avec le fait
d'ouverture ou de clôture du dossier
pénal d'après notre législation en
dossier pénal devait être entamée qu'en
présence d'effets nécessaire ce qui
n'est pas lié avec un ce qui n'est pas
lié à l'utilisation de cette procédure
deux commissions rogatoires avec
d'autres pays nous avons des documents
large comme ça que nous avons envoyé
dans tous les pays et doit être
indisponible journalistes des commos
créer d'autres médias mais lorsque
tout d'abord
aujourd'hui même on n'a pas reçu de
réponse à la question qui est venu
chercher avec ses avanies parce que
d'après les données objectif l'avion qui
est venu à rome ce que pour le
transporter cet avion a été
amarré une journée avant son soi-disant
en pause le mans
pourquoi n'at-on pas eu de reçu les
questions
déposées dans le parlement
c'était facto logique comment c'était de
passer que le pilote
qui voulait pas que pesci reprennent à
cette bouteille avec elle
pourquoi at il consenti un site c'était
on a eu en 6ème passage et tout ça est
ces questions ont été posées à au
parlement allemand bundestag pourquoi on
peut pas questionner pète chic les
allemands disent qu'il a n'a pas parlé
en aval nickel n'a pas visité à la
vanille dans la clinique est elle-même
elle témoigne qu'elle aa qu'elle a
visité cette beauté qui l a
qui l'emporterait avec elle on ne montre
à personne
nous demande de nous donner cette beauté
pour l'examen sont refusés et
cette déclaration que dans l'organisme
de alexis navale et ont été découverts
des agents interdit des agents
rempoissonnement ces déclarations ont
été faites après que dans la clinique de
charité a inclus clinique et civils là
on a trouvé et rien d'interdît par la
convention d'interdiction des armes
chimiques et c'est seulement dans la
clinique de bons desserts en trois jours
seulement qu'on a su
qu'on aurait su détecter ces agents
lorsque on a eu des situations avec les
skripal et on a demandé de ne pas se
faire guider par les laïcs les au fort
probablement et pour se faire guider par
les faits réels et ce soi-disant nunchuk
en amérique aux états unis on a 150
brevets à ce sujet et le même agent a
été développé en europe 6 et l'allemagne
la suède et d'autres nous ont portés
serment qu'ils n'avaient pas cette
technologie sans avoir cette technologie
en possession on ne peut pas en détecter
les résidus dans l'organisme en trois
jours ça chaque chimiste peux vous le
dire tout d'abord les allemands auront
dit qu'il ne donnerait pas parce que
c'était un informations militaires alors
c'est quoi ça vous nous accusez
d'un attentat de suicide et c'est le
secret alors on peut pas le faire si
vous êtes en participant aux nets de
convention d'interdiction des armes
chimiques alors ils ont dit alors nous
pouvons le donner mais c'est navalni
qu'il refuse qu'elle interdit alors
qu'est ce qu'on fait après et l'avocat
de navalni accusé dmitri peskov
d'avoir lancé des accusations contre
navalni pour
la coopération avec le ca y est ils
exigent d'aider des preuves ses preuves
well et a été visité par les employés de
les reconnaissances américaine c'est de
ça q dmitri peskov a parlé à lorsqu'une
aux exigeantes des preuves de ce crime
dont nos accuse on ne refuse lorsque on
s'est adressé à l'organisation
d'interdiction des armes nucléaires et
on leur demandait des résultats ils ont
répondu qu'ils pouvaient nous donner les
résultats qu'avec l'autorisation des
allemands et là c'est le cercle qui se
boucle et les et s'il vous plaît
attentivement les résultats on prétend
devoir retrouver les pôles estérase
soi-disant quelques agents qui d'après
leurs compositions sont semblables à
certains agents faisant partie de la
liste interdite par l'organisation
d'introduction d'armes nucléaires ils
n'ont pas donné de formules ni les
américains ni les suédois ni des
allemands et ça c'est le secret d'après
eux mais c'est dans la formule qu'on
peut trouver les preuves de la justice
ou du mensonge de ces déclarations pour
le moment je suis un peu en temps c'est
que l'occident n'a aucune épreuve et
tout ça ce n'est qu'une provocation et
alors j'ai déjà mentionné plus haut le
jours
d'amarrage de cet avion qui est venu
chercher navalni c'était avant
sa maladie et les allemands sont aussi
adressés saisi l'organisation
d'intervention d'armes nucléaires avant
même le cas
ensuite ils ont démenti cette demande
à l'organisation de l'édition d'art
nucléaire après que les allemands
l'autre se sont adressés à
l'organisation les employés de
secrétariat de cette organisation ont
caché nos pendant plusieurs jours
et ensuite ils ont avoué que les
allemands ont démandé donnerions nous
dire est-ce que ça hein génère pas de
soupçon avoue quant à moi si et encore
une fois j'invite tous les auditeurs dès
que moscou et de notre chaîne radieux de
prendre connaissance du matériel
disponible au site du ministère des
affaires étrangères où vous trouverez
des tout un tas de questions qui n'ont
pas reçu de réponse de la part de nos
collègues
occidentaux la question finale et après
l'interview va se terminer
sur la prof la question la plus
populaire aujourd'hui hier à bagnères y
aura-t-il une guerre avec l'ukraine on a
commencé par répondre à cette question
c'était la première question est déjà
commencer par celle qui suit vous avez
répondu d'une manière
beaucoup de choses ont changé en
l'espace d'une heure et demie en fait
si ça dépend de la fédération de russie
on aura pas de guerre mais moi j'exclus
pas
qu'il ya certains qui
désirent aider provoqué des hostilités
militaires et le régime de kiev n'est
pas en mesure de contrôler une grande
quantité d un militaire d'après les
données occidentaux on trouve à peu près
une centaine de milliers à la ligne de
contact et lé régime de kiev ne contrôle
pas une grande partie de ses troupes une
partie considérable des as détachement
qui sont déployés ce sont des anciens un
bataillon de bénévoles des bataillons de
défense territoriale des détachements de
défense et impopulaires je dirais et ils
sont maintenant armé pour des
lance-roquettes anti-char
au les demandes de de prendre avec des
fusils de chasse parce qu on aura pas d
alençon qui est anti char pour tout le
monde c'est en hystérie militariste et
là on a eu une crise de nerf dans
combattants qui a fait à fusiller qui a
tué ses cinq et commettent camarades
aussi pianiste
on va dire
président a déjà répondu à cette
question si elle esquive discuter veux
parler de la normalisation des relations
bilatérales
qui souffrent
du store porté par des actions
unilatérales de son régime est
évidemment on donne des réponses en
riposte à ces actions on est prêts on
est prêts on ne prête de l'accueillir à
moscou à sotchi à saint pétersbourg mais
s'il veut parler d'eux dans basse alors
là c'est le groupe de contact qui en est
chargée
par la décision du format normandie de
mener des négociations pour toutes les
questions des règlements directement
entre kiev et donetsk est lougansk
lorsqu'il déclare qu'il ne parlerait pas
à ces gens là
c'est mauvais mais c'est mauvais pour la
crise en termes du prêt yens mais pour
une relation s'il ya quelque chose à
dire celle à des propositions à réparer
les relations bilatérales
qui ont connu une dégradation grâce à
son prédécesseur et à lui même alors on
est prête à parler
moto à aller dans le groupe de contact
à corps une précision sur nos diplomates
je vous l on va effectuer
de
parler de cette hystérie qui est attisée
en ukraine avant tout par les forces et
par léman
des anglo saxon et de certains européens
et une partie de cette hystérie ce sont
ces déclarations exigent le départ du
pays le départ des citoyen qui sont
venus pour le propre affaire les
diplomates les
demandes de faire évacuer les familles
et le personnel à secondaire nous devons
le faire ne pouvons pas fermer les yeux
à ces choses là s'ils le font sans même
que les ukrainiens le demandent
peut-être eux ils ont
quelques projets à faire elles ont une
expérience assez riche à ce sujet
vous avez dit quelque chose à blinken
pendant la rencontre qu'est ce que vous
lui avez dit qu'après le retour il a
commencé à dire par là qu'on s'est parlé
du retour dans le match
et ils peuvent
te poses avait tort lorsque vous pensez
que j'ai perdu les
[Musique]
compressions de du contexte moi je lui
ai rien dit et ensuite elle m'a dit en
tête à tête j'espère que tenir ne va pas
sans trop foncée
malheur on sait pas
c'était un peu étrange pour moi et moi
je lui ai répondu
comme ça ouais je vous assure que nous
avons discuté exclusivement les
garanties de sécurité et ensuite moi
j'ai posé la question sur
l'inadmissibilité de
cette
situation avec nos missions
diplomatiques
réciproques et j'ai projets proposés et
on aura dans quelques semaines une
rencontre entre les spécialistes pour
traiter ces sujets là je peux vous
assurer qu'on ne parlait pas de menace
mais on ne peut pas ne pas analyser
le développement de la situation qu'est
ce qu'il ya derrière ces actions de nos
collègues anglo-saxons